Oh
you know I think that there's an element
in which the artist the lover in love
share similar characteristics and sort
of dispositions there is a willingness
to surrender there is a willingness to
give oneself to some higher meanings
there is something to be said for a
different kind of truth or subjectivity
for the truth as it plays out in your
own head I mean science has been
phenomenal at empirical investigations
and deconstructing the world into little
bits and pieces and isolating the
properties that constitute reality that
is all wonderful but as Verner Hertzog
says there's another kind of truth
there's ecstatic truth it's a risk you
know the artist has to take that risk he
has to put himself in a sort of state of
heightened vulnerability he has to
disarm himself Freeman Dyson talks about
a new age of wonder in which literally a
new generation of artists will be
writing genomes with the fluency that
Blake and Byron wrote versus how might
these technological instruments empower
the artists empower the imagination we
try to smash our sense of separateness
and temples of fragmentation in the form
of electronic Buddhism the throbbing
base speeds temporarily dissolving the
self and allowing us to merge with the
other when we have sex the kind of Sutra
people talk about blending into one
another becoming one another entering
the subjective headspace of the other
this is a wonderful idea it reflects
Richard Holmes's book the age of wonder
where he talks about the 17th century
where the artists and the scientists
with friends were the astronomers were
poets they talked about the importance
of sort of interpretation subjective
experience although people in many ways
are afraid of that they're afraid of
letting go of their source of
individuated self when you pop out the
other side it was the best thing you
ever did ultimately those things we fear
the most end of being the greatest
therapies a life really does begin at
the edge of your comfort zone to take
that leap fall in love or die trying
you